traza la recta que representa una
relación proporcional entre jay y x
donde la tasa unitaria de cambio de jr
respecto a x es de 1 con dos tercios en
otras palabras un cambio de una unidad
en x corresponde un cambio de uno con
dos tercios de unidades en que escribe
la ecuación de la recta bueno déjenme
copio esto en lugar donde puede escribir
muy bien ahora recuerden que estamos
trabajando con una relación proporcional
por lo tanto desde la forma que es igual
a una constante acá por x y vamos a
hacer una pequeña tabla para tratar de
entender cómo se comporta esta relación
proporcional
si x vale 0 entonces no importa cuánto
valga acá ya siempre tiene que valer 0
porque la relación es proporcional acá
por 0 siempre va a ser cero así que el
punto cero cero tiene que estar en la
gráfica de mi relación proporcional este
punto aquí está en la gráfica la
relación ahora se aumentó a x en 1
entonces cuánto tiene que aumentar
después me están diciendo que un cambio
de una unidad en x corresponde a un
cambio de 1 con dos tercios de unidades
en uno con dos tercios es lo mismo que
cinco tercios por lo tanto voy a usar
cinco tercios es más fácil trabajar con
fracciones impropias 53 es ok si ahora
vuelvo a aumentar a x en 1 x ahora vale
entonces ya tiene que volver a aumentar
en cinco tercios unidad por lo tanto
ahora que vale diez tercios de unidad
ninguno de estos dos puntos tiene
coordenadas enteras así que graficar lo
está un poco complicado voy a volver a
cambiar x ahora va a valer 3 aumenten
una unidad por lo tanto ya aumenta en
cinco tercios de unidad y ahora llévale
15 tercios pero aquí
es lo mismo que 515 entre 35 de modo que
el punto 35 35 está en la gráfica de mi
relación la gráfica de mi relación
relación proporcional por lo tanto se
vería algo así
algo así más o menos
bien entonces noten que para noten
entonces noten que cada vez que cambia x
en una unidad de cambio cinco tercios
cuando x cambio en una unidad y aumento
en cinco tercios también de aquí acá y
se corresponde con el mismo cambio acá
bueno y cuál es la pendiente esta recta
pues la pendiente es el alza entre el
avance el cambio y entre el cambio en x
aquí yo tengo un cambio en x un cambio
en x de tres unidades pasó de valer cero
de valer 0 a valer 3 por lo tanto es
como si me viniera de aquí hasta acá me
cambio en x es de 3 unidades y me cambió
en de cuánto es pues pasó de valer 0 a
valer 5 por lo tanto me cambio en y
es de 5 también lo podría haber leído
aquí en la tabla sería como ir de aquí
del 0 hasta este 5 el cambio es de 5 de
modo que la pendiente que se define como
el cambio en el cambio en x cambia entre
el cambio en x
sería de pues cuánto es el cambio es de
5 y el cambio en x es de 3 por lo tanto
la pendiente sería de 5 tercios que es
lo mismo que uno con dos tercios esto de
aquí esto de aquí es precisamente la
pendiente de la recta ahora para
encontrar la ecuación
pues yo sé que la ecuación de la recta
es de esta forma de aquí por lo tanto
tomando cualesquiera de estas parejas de
valores puedo sustituir las acá y
reducir el valor de acá si x vale 3 si x
vale 3 entonces lleva el 5 de modo que 5
es igual a k por equis pero x en este
caso vale 3 si ahora yo divido todo
entre 3 vivido toda esta ecuación entre
entre 3 entre 3 este se cancela con este
3 y obtengo que acá es igual a 5 tercios
de modo que la ecuación se convierte en
que es igual a
cinco tercios de x vamos a verificarlo
regresando al sitio teníamos el punto 0
0 y el punto 3 535 y la ecuación era que
es igual a 5 tercios de x vamos a checar
la respuesta
y estamos en lo correcto